[Music]
when heavily pregnant chulip Siddiq MP
was forced to choose between voting on
brexit and giving birth she chose voting
delaying a c-section and attending
Parliament in a wheelchair now another
female MP Stella Creasy says she carried
on constituency work during too painful
miscarriages pregnant again she says the
lack of maternity cover for MPs means
she's forced to choose between giving
her constituents the support they
deserve and being a mother
if someone carrying out another
important public service a GP or a vicar
for example were on leave a locum would
be provided to cover them but when it
comes to our MPs they're having to make
unacceptable choices between doing their
job and having a family but this isn't
just about parliamentarians they are
just one of the examples of gaps in
provisions that have left the UK ranked
one of the worst places in Europe for
paid parental leave
I applaud female MPs for speaking out
but why should they have to go public
about the intimate details of their
pregnancies to force change breaking
news women have babies time to adapt our
institutions accordingly as well I have
nothing to say about from yeah-yeah-yeah
Stella's a good friend of mine and my
local MP as you know as a wolfenstein
girl and I think for her this is
something that she was so passionate
about which is why she revealed the two
miscarriages you know that's been a very
difficult issue for her and her partner
and having a baby something she's always
wanted and obviously they had
difficulties and it's not something that
she wanted to talk about publicly but
when faced with this problem and
realizing that she can't just stand up
for herself she also has to stand up for
other female MPs that's why she went
public and and I completely agree with
you it has to be addressed and and
actually let's hear what's chulip said
because she spoke about the very thing
you talked about in your intro the hours
are incredibly unfriendly
for families so you know I voted at 1
a.m. 2 a.m. and not only is it
unfriendly to families it's also should
you really be making decisions about the
country at 1 a.m. or 2 a.m. I did for me
it doesn't feel like the right thing to
do and it's not just women it's not good
for anyone it's not good for family
anyone who has children or other caring
responsibilities I have to live like
that and just before I know your Keens
come in but I just want to let you hear
from Stella Creasy because we've been
talking about her I think her very brave
decision to talk about something that
must have been very painful to speak
about publicly
we have proxy leave thanks to the work
of Harriet Harman and tulip Sadiq that
allows somebody else to vote in
Parliament on my behalf if I take six
months maternity leave but they said to
me they don't recognize the MPs go on
maternity leave and eventually they said
well if I wanted to I could make an
application to prove that I had an
impact in my local community I simply
don't think it's fair that my local
community will be penalized for having a
woman as the MP because if sir is living
in 1919 not 2019 I mean there's no
defending that is there well it's just
tell you what it's a independent
parliamentary Standards Authority says
we do not comment on the arrangements of
individual MPs MPs have paid their
79,000 468 pounds salary in full from
the day they are elected to the day they
leave office regardless of whether they
take time off maternity or paternity
leave we can also make provisions for
MPs or their staff taking maternity
leave by allowing that MPs office to
high extra people it comes probably with
you until we heard there that they take
objection to having to take votes at 1
a.m. or 2 a.m. look these people and
most of them I agree a lot of them get
an unfair and a very critical press
unfairly they come in because they seek
to help govern the country it's a tough
job
it doesn't by the way I'm totally
supportive you so please there are two
strands running here so I support but
the idea that I'm having to take votes
at 1:00 or 2:00 in the morning well you
know I've worked in newspapers sometimes
I'm still filing copy it one more you
don't complain that comes with the turf
so I'm with you on that but moaning that
you've got a long day at the office I'm
sorry I can't support that there's a
long day at the office and there's both
yes interesting you mention Fleet Street
because that actually is an example of
an industry that was notoriously and
yeah and biased against women and that
women have taught Maurice
about their experiences of being in an
environment it was very hostile to them
in terms of their needs and again it
should be for like caramello would stand
in the parlor than anybody and still we
were just accepted you know we should
make clear you said it in that same
there women do get six months paid
maternity leave and I think what Stella
Chris is talking about is the extra
money you get for constituency work
thing and she you do have to apply sorry
just to clarify no she's saying she's
not getting paid her maternity leave
she's saying that there was no cover for
addictions if she takes at least she's
out to get the money I'm I'm with
YouTube you know the problem is there is
no historic policy on maternity leave
and I think in decades gone by the women
who wear em pays what either older women
who had grown up children or they were
women who didn't have children at all
and what's happened is policy has not
kept up with the changing times and
there's no way in 2019 that a woman MP
should be treated worse or any
differently from a male MP but I agree
with you you can't change the
institution of parliament in the voting
for women who want to go home with ten
so you agree that there should be cover
for female and PISA go on maternity yes
yeah but in Denmark they actually do
that they actually have a standing in
Denver so yeah I don't think that's
beyond the pale but we agree all sorts
of self-employed people no just thinking
about em please if you if you run your
own business you might get some money
but you someone else is gonna run that
business but you're not the key public
service so it's the public that miss out
it's not just a question of you know but
the point the point she has is she's not
losing money she gets maternity cover
her concern is that if she takes it her
constituents will not be being
represented by their impotent and it's
actually very thoughtless and if you
were working here or the BBC or
something like that actually you get
your maternity leave and they put
someone else in to the place of the job
and that's the point she's making it she
wants someone else in to go and do that
work which I agree booth and it's a
British shame agree to she had to
describe in such graphic detail about
what it was like for her and I mean I
can say cause even German she was
talking about how she had to go around
the streets working
aching and bleeding and that is a
Pauling foreign ops in this daily
fragile it's coming to your second the
second point the USO which was about
that the hours MPs were nails to
actually they did change them some time
ago and then they got changed back cuz
for a lot of that being with male MPs
who come from different parts of the
country they want to spend the evening
in I know in peas on both sides of the
political spectrum who are from a
different generation who have complained
about the impact on their family life
short of them being expected to vote at
one or two M's not just that often there
are men who actually like to get home
really one time even maybe make dinner
for their father so how often do they
have one or two am folks come on our
floor often enough it's not just and
deny the hours are antisocial bananas
designed around this behavior there is
no need to do the hours they do you
could change the hours very easily the
truth is that a lot of them have got
other jobs as well and therefore they
want the time to go and do the other
jobs actually they did change them all
at one time remember they change them
back yes yes i mean this whole thing is
bittersweet for me because i really do
applaud the female MPs who have who are
causing this change but I also feel
resentful that they have to put
themselves in this position I mean when
I saw Tunip Sadiq when she's in a
wheelchair voting when she was supposed
to be giving birth horrible there's
nobody in that system so if I'm an MP
and I'm here or whenever I might be I
can ring you and say look both of us you
you were gonna vote
I remember how that broke down that
relies YES on the pairing system during
one of the bricks that relies on trust
[Laughter]
needs to do what and how well I think
there needs to be I mean the idea that
you would have to prove as an asset can
I get my turn to cover constituents need
an MP if their MP has a baby and they
should be able to have that as right and
I
not a selfish demand she's saying that
her constituents need a survey it's not
the creature that's done it she's well
respected seeing is a great MP and I
think she'll change it by doing this
you're changing it saying they do
provide additional funding listen all
you have to do is apply for it and they
just ask for an excellent explanation of
how you can use it there's no one's
applied for it and received it so the
potentially it's there in theory but
it's clearly not working well that's
almost it for this week but before we go
more balls okay the grass has been
prepped the Pimm's is mixed the
strawberries and cream are ready to
serve with only a few days to go the
countdown to Wimbledon is well and truly
on but don't be surprised if you hear
more chance of come on Fran than come on
Andy from The Spectator stands there's a
new plucky Brit in town and she's got
one hell of a backstory Fran Jones is
this year's wild card as she hopes to
game set and match her way right to the
top despite only having six fingers and
seven toes the 18 year old tennis star
was born with a rare genetic disorder
which affects her balance and the way
she grips her racket but Fran has defied
medical experts who said that she would
never make it as a tennis player by
landing a place at the championships
here's what she had to say I always say
the greatest pleasure in life is doing
what people say you cannot do I'd say
that's my motto and then I definitely
live by it and I think that will be
something that I strive for throughout
the rest of my life and certainly
throughout the rest of my career and
yeah I don't think anyone should be
limited by other people's opinions you
cannot be serious if you think this girl
isn't going places with an attitude like
that Fran Jones you are our straight
talker of the week nibbles please
that is very wimbledon native what do
you think of it one time in the year
where the place I live actually becomes
interesting
hey it's because of characters like
that's amazing story I don't
she's got to fight through she's good at
the edge well that's it from us this
week but if you want to join in the
debate just search the pledge on
Facebook or Twitter and don't forget you
can now listen to the program on the go
with Apple podcasts thanks for watching
and we'll see you next time
[Music]